well let's go live now to Tehran where
the head of Iran's Civil Aviation
Organization is speaking to the press
let's listen to Ali Abdullah late still
conducting investigations however before
I start I would like to address the
Iranian people saying that the recent
statements made by the Ukrainian and
American parties and other statements
made by politicians as you know the
matter is of complex technical details
Canada and Iran together with Ukraine
are following up with the investigations
and once a technical report is concluded
they will be presented to the Ukrainian
and Canadian leaders and entered they
will disclose the outcomes to the whole
world and as you may notice that the
latest information we have we are
presented and circulated on time if they
have technical proof they can come
forward and presented this is a very
important point however considering the
fact that the information contained in
the black box or the aviation systems
including the recent conversation
between the pilot these pieces of
informations are very critical there are
hundreds of technical points that should
be addressed before reaching a
conclusion there
or any statement made before extracting
the information contained in the black
box are groundless however I would like
to assure that the craft was not hit by
a missile it the craft suffered flames
for one and a half minutes after taking
off as a result the pilot decided to
return to the airport however he had
many technical issues at hand and his
top priority was to save the passengers
after taking off minutes from taking off
he contacted the control tower and he
before that he requested permission to
climb up to 26,000 feet therefore it is
not appropriate to jump to conclusions
once the information contained in the
black box we will be able to establish
what happens what happens in such a
situation the information contained in
the black box are extracted then
analyzed in order to establish the
condition of the craft and the piles as
well however I assure you again it is a
very complex and complicated case we
have the necessary equipment to do so
yet this particular incident is of great
complexity and since the passengers are
of different nationalities we are
expecting some other countries to step
forward and come join the investigations
and
and a helping hand we ask your
permission for mr. Dai to join in order
to shed light on some of the technical
details this morning we started our
investigations into different courses we
had a security meeting with our
colleagues we had another technical
meeting on how to extract the
information contained in the black box
we also had a meeting with Ukrainian
officials we are employing technical
engineers responsible for extracting
data from black box
they are Iranians and as you know any
courier has the ability to extract
information and data from the black box
3 runyan companies have the up-to-date
sophisticated equipment necessary to
extracting the data from the black box
we will also retain experts and
professionals from aviation incidents in
the Iranian national carrier we also had
a meeting with the investigation
committee and presence of the Ukrainian
officials they also on the part confirm
that the black box suffered certain
damages however the conversation between
the pilot and the control that the
control tower is obtained
we are carrying initial investigations
at Mehrabad Airport and this preliminary
assessment will be concluded today we
are also seeking possibilities on how to
repair the damaged blade black box in
case the other of Ukrainian officials
have any suggestions with respect to how
to repair the damaged box they can come
forward at the same time we have
existing cooperation agreement with
other countries like Russia we have
established four points where we are
will be able to extract the information
contained in the black box
if we fail other four countries Canada
Ukrainian of the United States and
Russia have expressed their preparedness
to cooperate however it is very much
likely that the data contained in the
black box can be extracted by our own
experts however if we come to conclusion
that the information contained in the
black box cannot be extracted and the
Iranian technical experts failed to do
so we may seek assistance from one of
these four countries
if you're just joining us here on
al-jazeera we have been listening in to
a press conference coming from Tehran
where the head of Iran's Civil Aviation
Organization has been speaking to the
press his name is ali abbas our day and
he started off by addressing the iranian
people about these accusations that the
plane was hit by a missile the headline
so far from this press conference is
that the iranian see unequivocally based
on what they know from pilot recordings
and other technical insinuations that
the plane was not hit by a missile what
they're asking is that the international
community holds on until they have all
the technical information let's go back
and continue to listen in said the pilot
was in contact was in contact with the
control tower after taking off he
communicated the airport and he sought
permission to climb up to a higher level
that's what he did after the takeoff the
plane was well airborne and he found a
chance to communicate with the airport
he spoke with the control tower in
Mehrabad Airport seeking permission to
take the second altitude that's why he
sought and he obtained permission to
climb up to 26,000 feet after that fire
broke out in the crack for two minutes
what happened between these two points
at that point it is it was natural for
the pilot to seek permission to return
to the airport
however he should press the
communication tool in order to establish
communication with the airport however
we believe he was trying to do his best
to salvage the situation as you know
there is audio recording in the cockpit
[Music]
how long the investigation will be will
run before we reach a final conclusion
according to the preliminary
investigation 12 technical committees
have been formed they are responsible
for analyzing data these 12 committees
are supposed also to examine the crash
site I believe three days have passed we
have covered a good distance in terms of
the investigations and now we have come
into the technical investigations on the
crash scene and as you know this is a
very complicated process at the same
time we are trying to extract the data
contained in the black box this has to
be done first as we stand the situation
is not cleared however I assure you that
the craft was not hit by a missile as
falsely reported the Americans claimed
they had our imposition of certain
documents prove that the craft was
downed by Iranian missiles by mistake
this or these statements were made by
American officials if they are truly in
position of documents proving these
claims they will or they are required to
step forward and present these documents
to the whole world I believe these are
technically this these are totally
political issues and these are political
statements some of the public were able
to catch some amateur videos were you
able to examine these as well yes I have
myself examined these amateur videos and
as you know these were taken by average
common people
however these videos show that the craft
was inflamed and continued to be in
flames for 60 or 70 seconds also these
videos show that the craft was not hit
by a missile or anything else it is
natural that if the craft was hit by a
missile it would drop to the ground
immediately it was clear that the craft
cold flames and it continued to to be so
for 60 70 seconds if the missile had
been hit by a missile the debris would
have scattered over a large area if you
may call the Ukrainian craft that would
hit by a missile we can recall that the
debris fell over a vast area on the
ground
find a mosque
16 to 17 Swedish people were on board
the craft
did you invite the Swedish authorities
to join the investigations yes we
communicated with Sweden and Canada in
order to be closely monitoring the
investigations such a request from our
part to these countries prove that we
are genuine and we are taking the
necessary steps and we are keen on
having all the parties interested come
closely monitor and follow up with the
current investigations these discussions
were raised with respect to the delay
[Music]
the flight the craft landed earlier at
in Iran both the pilots went to the
hotel for rest however three they took
rest only for three hours the plane
at the beginning delayed the flight and
I believe it was a Christmas holiday and
the majority of the passengers were
carrying
many luggages that's why the boarding
process took a long period of time
passengers started to board and as you
know also the weather conditions were
not suitable the pilot at that time
wanted to make sure that he had
sufficient fuel and he requested for
more fuel it was notable that the fuel
he requested the number of passengers
and the way to flag it is in excess of
what the craft could carry that's why
the pilot should have loaded off some of
the luggage it is this coal must be made
by the pilot himself he is the one
responsible for taking such a decision
either to load off certain luggage or
certain passenger that would be a reason
for delaying the flight
some of the luggage will load it off and
they were supposed to be carried forward
on a different flight this is a normal
process and it is natural and it is
being carried out at any flight at any
Airport at any given time
these circumstances this craft is
insured by Ukraine the Ukrainian carrier
and the insurance company will pay
compensation to the carrier which is the
Ukrainian Airlines we have also Chicago
Alliance and we have a Chicago and Tokyo
treaties and we should first establish
the craft is insured by which insurer
and covered under which agreement that's
why the Ukrainian carrier must present
the relevant insurance documents and in
turn these compensations will be offered
to the relatives of victims however it
is known that compensations will be paid
to the victims including the Iranians
the Ukraine international is responsible
for paying compensation however the this
carrier of course is covered under
insurance and these matters will be
resolved between the carrier and the
insurance companies before compensations
are paid to the victims either in u.s.
dollars Ukrainian currency or Iranian
one as you may know this is a very huge
incident it is a huge massive incident
investigations will drag for a long
period of time it may even extend over
one or two years extracting data from
the black box also may take a month or
two
what we are asking the public and
officials alike is to maintain calm and
help us carry the investigations forward
in order to establish the conclusion
well we've just been listening into that
press conference in Tehran we started
off by hearing the head of Iran's Civil
Aviation Organization and then mr. Zayed
who brought us up to date on exactly
where they are with their investigations
into what happened with the play in the
main headline is that according to the
Iranian from their investigation so far
it was not hit by a missile they
maintained the plane was on fire for a
few minutes and they also say that the
videos that have been circulating back
that up but the plane was on fire for a
few minutes before it tried to return to
the airport well there was plenty more
in that press conference and I'm going
to bring in our correspondent acid Baek
who's in Tehran to help us unpick some
of it and I said there was a lot said
there just give us the headlines to
start with well there was definitely a
lot said there more information than we
expected so Iran is still maintaining
that this aircraft was not struck by a
missile now the aviation authority here
did say that there was some amateur
footage however they didn't verify that
New York Times footage that showed a
projectile going up and apparently
hitting some sort of aircraft but what
they did say was they gave us a bit more
information about the flight they said
that it caught fire for about a minute
and a half to two minutes he said that
the pilot did contact Mehrabad Airport
which isn't the Imam how many airport
Mehrabad Airport is a domestic airport
that deals with domestic flights here
and Iran he said that he sought
permission to climb to a higher altitude
of 26,000 feet now they've said that
they recovered the black box with the
data and that they will try to recover
that they feel that they have the
expertise to recover it but if they
don't they will seek assistance from
other countries such as Canada the u.s.
Ukraine but it feels like that the
aviation authority
is trying to be as transparent as
possible giving us a lot of information
taking into account what's been said by
the United States and other than Canada
about the missile strike but they've
rejected categorically the head of the
aviation authority here that he was hit
by a missile and he said if it was it
would have the wreckage would have
spread over a vast area and he cited the
UK the plane that was hit in Ukraine and
how the by missile and had that record
just spread over a vast area and he says
that this is very different but we're
getting the extra information because
before we thought and what was said was
that the pilot had not communicated but
now we're hearing that he did
communicate with Mehrabad Airport
requesting to climb to a higher altitude
he made the point acid it several times
didn't he that they've started with
these twelve technical committees
they've also been talking with the
Ukrainians but he pointed out that
starting with just extracting that data
from the black box takes time and that
it will take months potentially even
years and his final comment was really
you know the international community
should come forward with any information
that they have but also please be
patient yes because there's a lot of
statements that have been made and he's
and he cited just certain US officials
that say that they have documents to say
that this aircraft was hit with by a
missile now the Iranians are saying if
you have this proof if you have this
evidence then come forward with it and
any other countries that have any
information that can help out with this
investigation
then please let us know now we
understand that the Ukrainian officials
are already here in Iran they've sat in
on the investigation meeting they're
very much a part of the process but yes
this investigation could take some time
he said that if we cannot he also said
that the black box has been damaged and
they're looking to repair it but they
are confident that there are four
companies within Iran that can extract
that information but if they if they
can't that they will seek help from
other countries but again
this is Iran I think on the defensive
somewhat I don't think that they
expected these allegations the dot and
didn't expect the countries other
countries around the world to kind of
join in the chorus of suspicion saying
that this aircraft was hit by missiles
so we're getting a bit more information
especially about the pilot and the
communication he they say that he did
try to turn the airplane around and his
priority was to save the aircraft and
the passengers
I said beg now joining with the latest
on that press conference giving us more
information about what's happening
regarding the airliner downing in Iran I
said thank you